the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another ones of winner update
video
that's right folks george r martin has
given us another update on his not a
blog website
as you all know george r martin is
currently writing the wins of winner
the next book that is slated to be
released in the song of ice and fire
series
this is a book that he has been writing
for nearly a decade
and since i made a wins of winner update
video only a week ago
i typically would not make another one
so fast but this time george r martin
did give us some insight into his
writing schedule
i thought some of you might find this to
be as interesting as i did
it seems as if these updates are
happening more frequently which does
make me want to believe he is almost
done
however i have felt this way for many
many years so who really knows
you know how it is right when we all
start thinking they will announce a
release date
we end up finding out it has been
delayed once again
this is something i discussed in my last
update video
george said the book would be done by
this summer but he recently announced it
would be delayed until next summer
at the very least now the good news is
as of right now he does seem to be
moving along nicely
this is one of the main reasons why he
has given us several updates this summer
so let's have a look at what he said
about the winds of winter yesterday
on his not a blog website george r
martin said i am back in my
fortress of solitude again my isolated
mountain cabin
i'd returned to santa fe for a short
visit to spend some time with paris
deal with some local business that had
piled up during my months away
and of course fulfill my duties to con
zealand the virtual road con
but all that's behind me now and i am
back on the mountain again
which means i am back in westeros again
once more moving ahead with winds of
winter
it is curious how my life has evolved i
mean once upon a time
i actually wrote my books and stories in
the house where i lived
in a home office but some decades ago
wanting more solitude
i bought the house across the street and
made that my writer's retreat
no longer would i write all day in my
red flannel bathrobe
now i would have to dress and put on
shoes and walk all the way across the
street to write
but that worked for a while things
started getting busier though
so busy that i needed a full-time
assistant then the office house had
someone else in it
not just me and my characters and then i
hired a second assistant
and a third and there was more mail more
email
more phone calls and more people coming
by by now
i'm up to five assistants and somewhere
in there i also acquired a movie theater
a bookstore a charitable foundation
investments
a business manager and despite all that
help
i was drowning till i found the mountain
cabin my life up here is very boring
it must be said truth be told i hardly
can be said to have a life
i have one assistant with me at all
times minions i call them
the assistants do two week shifts and
have to stay in quarantine at home
before starting a shift
every morning i wake up and go straight
to the computer where my minions bring
me coffee
i am utterly useless and incoherent
without my morning coffee
and juice and sometimes a light
breakfast then i start to write
sometimes i stay at it until dark other
days i break off in the late afternoon
to answer emails
or return urgent phone calls my
assistant brings me food and drink from
time to time
when i finally break off for the day
usually around sunset
there's dinner then we watch television
or screen a movie
the wi-fi sucks up on the mountain
though so the choices are limited
some nights i read instead i always read
a bit before going to sleep
when a book really grabs hold of me i
may read half the night but that's rare
i sleep the next day i wake up and do
the same
the next day the next day the next day
before covid
i would usually get out once a week or
so to eat at a restaurant
or go to the movies that all ended in
march since then
weeks and months go by when i never
leave the cabin or see another human
being except whoever is on duty that
week
i lose track of what day it is what week
it is what month it is
the time seems to go by very fast it is
now
august and i don't know what happened to
july but it is good for the writing
i wonder if it is the same for other
writers or is it just me
i wonder if i'll ever figure out the
secret of having a life and writing a
book at the very same time
i certainly have not figured it out to
date for the nonce
it is what it is my life is at home on
hold
and i am spending the days in westeros
with my pals mel
and sam and vic and tai and that girl
with no name
over there in braavos well as you can
see
it does sound like he is focused on
finishing this next book
it's a shame he has to isolate himself
in a cabin in the woods just to do so
i think that if he would have focused on
the wins of winner from day one
i'm sure he would have had it done many
years ago but you also have to think
if he did that then he would not be able
to help with any new shows
or write any other books like fire and
blood i think most fans would rather
have the winds of winter before anything
else
but i do understand where george is
coming from sometimes you do actually
get cabin fever
and sometimes you get tired of working
on the same thing over and over again
it can be nice to take a break and focus
on something else especially if you find
yourself having writer's block
you might have to take a step back
re-energize then come back at it
feeling motivated again hopefully george
is able to take advantage of all this
momentum
by actually getting the book done within
the next year it would be amazing if the
winds of winter came out
then was followed up by house of the
dragon that would certainly give us
enough material to discuss for the next
decade while waiting for a dream of
spring
now this is all wishful thinking of
course since george r martin
is isolating himself in a cabin in the
woods there is really no excuse for him
not finishing this book sometime soon
now if i were him i would not even think
about writing one word for the second
volume of fire and blood
until i got the winds of winter done i
think everyone else who is in business
with him would understand
a game of thrones and more specifically
a song of ice and fire is what led to
all these other opportunities
as of right now the winds of winter is
holding him back from finishing his a
song of ice and fire book series
if he can get through that obstacle i
really think it would enhance
all of his other works simply because of
the amount of stress he is under while
trying to finish it but
then again i know nothing all i really
want to say is i am very excited for the
future of this fandom
i mean yeah game of thrones might not
have ended the way we all wanted
but we have yet to see how the creator
of this amazing story wants it to end
based on how incredible his books have
been so far i can only assume the wins
of winner
will take things to the next level as we
reach the climax of the story
house of the dragon is on its way and
the winds of winter will get released
eventually which will bring us one step
closer to
a dream of spring anyways i hope you all
found this update video to be as
interesting as i did
let me know what you think down below as
always i want to thank everyone for
watching the video
and i also want to thank those of you
who support my channel on patreon
i could not do this without you have a
great day everyone
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you